Welcome back everyone happy new year this will
be my spider-man no way home video for all the
changes that they made to tobey maguire and
andrew garfield's timeline of movies because
they made a lot of changes to the characters that
basically changed the timeline of all their films
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's a bunch
of really big stuff coming up and even though the
movie's been out for several weeks i will say one
more big spoiler warning hopefully you've had a
chance to see the movie god help you if you happen
but during the end of spider-man no way home
toby maguire in andrew garfield's versions
of spider-man helped tom holland cure all the
sinister six characters either de-powering them
returning them to their original human forms
and in the case of willem dafoe's green goblin
removing all traces of the goblin serum from his
body effectively erasing the goblin personality
and just because doctor strange performs a second
spell to make everyone forget tom holland's peter
parker exists entirely it does not erase what all
three versions of spider-man have done to cure the
sinister six characters but the spell does send
them all back to their original universes in the
different time periods they all came from because
all the sinister six villains had been pulled to
the mcu right before the moments of their deaths
but toby mcguire and andrew garfield's versions of
spider-man were pulled from the present day of
each of their universes which is why they look
so much older but the sinister six characters look
the same age as when they did in their last movies
for example in real life toby maguire is now the
same age as willem dafoe was when he played green
goblin for the first time in that first spider-man
movie that's how long it's been don't you feel old
now so when doctor strange sends all these cured
villains back it effectively changes the endings
of all the tobey maguire spider-man movies the
endings of the andrew garfield amazing spider-man
movies like all their timelines are different now
and i know there's some confusion as to whether
toby maguire and andrew garfield will remember
tom holland's mcu spider-man or if the memory
spell wiped them too because the whole reason why
everyone was brought to the mcu in the first place
is because they knew a version of peter parker
was spider-man so just to clarify the second spell
doesn't make everyone forget about mcu spider-man
they just forget about mcu peter parker so toby
maguire andrew garfield all the sinister six films
will remember one that there is a multiverse with
other versions of spider-man out there and two
they'll remember the mcu spider-man who helped
cure them the only part that they'll forget is
that mcu peter parker was part of all this they'll
think back on the adventure and just remember that
other version of spider-man that helped them like
the other brother from the multiverse i always
wanted brothers the writers of the movie did admit
that there were some plot holes with the memory
spell explainer unanswered questions but the
marvel and sony people intended to leave it to the
spider-man 4 movie to answer all those lingering
questions like did the second spell also delete
all the computer records of peter parker's birth
his school records his social security number
stuff like that they're basically saying they'll
deal with that during spider-man 4. like whoever
winds up making that movie whoever directs it
will just make that decision but now you ask how
are toby mcguire and andrew garfield's timelines
different so you have to remember the loki rules
for time travel and you also have to think of it
as the marvel cinematic multiverse because we're
doing so much multiverse storytelling like they've
canonized the events of all the tobey maguire
spider-man movies andrew garfield spider-man
movies and the tom hardy venom movies to the mcu
now changing the past doesn't change the future
think about it if you travel to the past that
past becomes your future and your former present
becomes the past which can't now be changed
by your new future so back to the future is a
bunch of so the way they explain time travel the
multiverse during avengers end game in the loki
series as well is that you can't change your past
you can only create branch timelines from that
original timeline but funny side note now toby
maguire's first spider-man movie is technically
the first mcu movie it's not iron man anymore
so what happens when all these villains and toby
maguire andrew garfield get sent back to where
they came from is that they are now variants in
branch timeline versions of the events of all
their movies or at least where they came from
because toby maguire and andrew garfield didn't
come from one of their movies they came from
points in their timelines way beyond where their
previous movies ended but starting with green
goblin here he suddenly shows up during this final
fight at the end of the first spider-man movie
he's cured he's not evil anymore it's implied he
doesn't die like he's not impaled by his glider
and because it's only the older tobey maguire
later in his timeline who experienced no way home
norman osborn here like the new cured version
has to do a lot of fast talking to convince
this young version of toby that he's better now
and just vows to make amends for what he's done
but now going forward in their timeline he's a
variant he creates a branch timeline where he's
no longer green goblin after this couple years go
by norman osborn is still alive for the events of
spider-man 2 when doctor octopus has his accident
with the arms it sounds like he and doctor octopus
knew each other prior to the events of both of
their films so because this version of norman
osborn in this new branch timeline is good he's
able to help toby maguire spider-man deal with
doctor octopus after he goes off the rails save
him even faster and because norman osborn didn't
die in this new branch timeline his harry osborn
doesn't wind up turning evil or becoming a version
of green goblin then later in their timeline when
they get to the events of spider-man 3 norman
osborn who's good doctor octopus who's been cured
as well are still alive and able to help toby deal
with a version of venom that comes along in the
version of sandman that comes along and fix both
of those situations without anybody else dying so
we'll call the branch timeline that's created by
this green goblin that goes back cured the best
possible timeline for a version of toby maguire
because in that timeline nobody dies everyone is
still alive on that planet this doctor octopus
goes back to the end of spider-man 2 now remember
he only changes things going forward he doesn't
change his past so there's a version of norman
osborn who still died in his universe but let's
assume that he goes back before he sacrificed
himself before he turned on the fusion reactor so
he's able to survive past the end of spider-man 2.
he doesn't have to sacrifice himself he'd still be
alive for the events of a version of spider-man 3
enabled to help toby maguire spider-man deal with
sandman and venom and harry osborn green goblin
because remember a version of green goblin would
have still died in that timeline but he's able to
help save everyone so a version of harry osborn
doesn't die in that timeline and they're able to
stop venom faster they're able to cure sandman
faster then this version of sandman goes back to
a branch timeline version of spider-man 3 where
he doesn't wind up teaming up with venom making
it easier for toby maguire to stop venom before
he can kill harry osborn green goblin but in the
timeline that he goes back to doctor octopus still
died during the events of spider-man 2 years
prior so that's why i say the best possible
timeline for a version of tobey maguire would
be the one the green goblin goes back to changed
and it's the same branch timeline explainer for
how the andrew garfield amazing spider-man movie's
timeline changes lizard goes back to the end of
amazing spider-man 1 survives then is able to help
andrew garfield deal with the version of electro
and green goblin when they pop up later they save
everyone this harry osborn probably never turns
evil never kills gwen stacy so that's the best
possible branch timeline for a version of andrew
garfield spider-man this electro goes back to the
end of amazing spider-man 2 a little bit later
in the timeline is able to help andrew garfield
his subsequent fight with green goblin goes down
a little bit differently and he never winds up
killing gwen stacy but then we also have two other
new branch timelines created by the older tobey
maguire and older andrew garfield when they go
back to the present day of each of their universes
when they go back everything they experienced
in their original movies still went down the
exact same way no changes there like they didn't
change any of their past they only create a branch
timeline with an alternate future but they go
forward in each of the new branch timelines
with the knowledge that they were able to cure
versions of their villains like they have more
hopeful positive outlooks on their futures like
this andrew garfield spider-man isn't bitter
or rageful anymore he starts turning back into
more of a friendly neighborhood spider-man and
makes his peace with gwen stacy's death but he
doesn't go back to a universe where she's alive
she's still dead for this version of andrew but
because he goes back knowing about the multiverse
and what they did he knows there's versions of
himself out there living with versions of gwen
stacy who didn't die i'd argue that the new branch
timeline that this older toby maguire creates when
he goes back is the least changed of any of the
characters it's implied that he'd already made
his peace with all the bad stuff that had happened
to him all the bad stuff that he'd done he'd moved
past it a long time ago and was living his best
life with a version of mary jane they had a family
together so he didn't change all that much during
the film he was the person giving all the pep
talks to all the other versions of spider-man it's
really andrew garfield spider-man that still had a
lot of soul-searching to do and obviously tom hall
and spider-man changed the most of all of them
so there any questions about how the events of
all the toby movies and all the andrew movies
changed they didn't change the events of those
movies they just created new branch timelines
for each of these versions that went back to where
they came from every one of these characters that
goes back changed at the end of the movie is now
a variant living in a branch timeline version of
their original movies like i said it's not quite
as complicated as it sounds i'm sure there's still
going to be a billion questions about little plot
details there's always going to be little minor
plot holes that hopefully they answer with future
movies but if you do have any big questions about
how everything works just write them below
in the comments and i'll try to address it
during my future videos i'll do more tobey maguire
andrew garfield videos in the future because there
are rumors that they will be coming back for more
movies in the future for more crossovers there's
a bunch of big stuff coming up so make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
miss anything everyone click here to learn about
the spider-man no way home alternate ending for
the venom character in venom deleted scenes and
click here for my full doctor strange multiverse
of madness trailer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!